bonjour je m'appelle thbo jeanougin je
suis responsable de la programmation
culturelle de la ville de morepa
aujourd'hui j'ai choisi de vous parler
d'un spectacle qui se tiendra le 1er
mars chez nous on reçoit l'incroyable
pianiste Joakim
[Musique]
horsely les trois raisons d'aller voir
ce spectacle la première c'est que pour
découvrir par exemple Bethoven
schostakovic ou encore bac à la sauce
cubaine mais aussi pour découvrir Mozart
Chopin à la sauce afroocaribéenne et
enfin pour passer un moment unique aussi
en joué
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'inspiré
[Musique]
ce spectacle se tiendra donc à l'espace
Albert Camu le 1er
mars